welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka Darth initia
and with the Mandalorian season finale
dropping yesterday we finally got a look
at the series big bad working from the
shadows in typical Sawa's fashion Mothe
gideon has been behind the entire arc of
the season secretly hunting baby Oda and
using his puppet the client to get the
creature in order to achieve its goals
but who is the character and how does he
have one of the most valuable weapons in
the entire galaxy well throughout this
video we're gonna be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
Moff gideon including his backstory
career in the empire and giving our
theories on how he came to possess the
dark saber there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
watch episode 8 yet and don't want to
know what happens then I highly suggest
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of Mothe Gideon ok so we
actually got our first glimpse of Mothe
Gideon way back at the end of episode 5
of the Mandalorian this episode revolved
around mando tracking down a dangerous
bounty with the fresh-faced mercenary
named Toro are played by Jake can avail
this put them on the warpath with a
dangerous rogue Imperial soldier named
fennec SH and Toro was killed off and
it's a good thing too because he's been
slagging off the rise of skywalker on
instagram oh you'll not be featuring in
the MCU any time soon mate
though the two managed to take her down
the episode ended with a mysterious
character approaching her body and from
this little glimpse many were convinced
that this was bobba fett making the
return eagle-eyed viewers even lined up
the sounds of the characters spurs and
said how similar they were two sound
effects heard in the Return of the Jedi
to me though the cape was extremely
similar to the shots that we got of
Gideon in the trailer and this style was
something that fad never wore jon
favreau quickly dismissed these rumors
saying that Boba Fett would not be
appearing in the show and that the
season was going to be made up of
entirely new characters IMDB would later
go on to confirm that this was Gideon so
we now know for definite that this was
the characters first appearance he lay
low after this not returning until
episode
seven appearing as a hologram to the
client and then making a grand entrance
in a brand-new Outland TIE fighter it
was an awesome way to introduce the
character and it quickly propped him up
as one of the most intimidating villains
that we've seen in Star Wars for a long
time he pretty much had the characters
locked into a kill box and commanded a
wave of stormtroopers scout troopers and
the ever terrifying death troopers death
troopers made their first appearance in
rogue one and quickly became one of the
coolest looking aspects of that movie
they primarily work as bodyguards for
high-ranking Imperial officers and are
also masters of stealth marksmanship and
hand-to-hand combat death troopers are
trained to be exceptional and they
specialized in heavy weapons demolitions
and guerrilla warfare and some of the
deadliest Imperial soldiers that exist
in the galaxy hence their name we also
learned that before being promoted to
the rank of moth Gideon was a member of
the Imperial Security Bureau or ISB for
short this was a law enforcement branch
and intelligence agency of the Empire
that pretty much worked as their version
of Internal Affairs they were in charge
of State Security and Gideon was tasked
with weeding out those who may be
disloyal to the cause before they
defected to the rebellion in order to
achieve a position in the ISB imperial
officers have to show staples of loyalty
towards the Empire and thus only the
most dedicated a picta join their ranks
Gideon is adept at torture and weeding
out those who may betrayed the Empire
and due to this he has a high level of
abilities in espionage and infiltration
imagine a c12 from line a GE book but
with lightsabers
anyway lightsabers brings us to our next
question how is it that moth Gideon was
able to obtain the dark saber well we do
discover an episode 8 that during his
time in the IASB Gideon was tasked with
making sure that Mandalore and its
people remain loyal to the Empire and he
took part in a massacre of the planet's
population that was later labeled the
night of a thousand tears this great
purge pretty much wiped out the majority
of the planet and sent those who
survived into hiding Gideon was so
instrumental in this genocide that man
no even knows his name based purely off
reputation and his actions during this
purge Gideon not only seized the secret
record of Mandalorian identities during
this time but it also looks like he
gained the dock saber as well the dark
saber is actually a ceremonial
Mandalorian weapon that was created by
the first-ever Mandalorian to be
inducted into the Jedi Order
since then the dark sabers been passed
down from generation to generation and
it's typically carried by the leader of
the Mandalorians those who are familiar
with the animated Star Wars series
rebels will know that the last
Mandalorian to wield the weapon was Bo
Catan who became leader of the people at
the end of the show at out that bulker
town were part with it willingly and
thus from this we can assume that gideon
killed her during the purge the dark
saber is a symbol of leadership in the
house of vislar and due to Mandalorian
customs one can only obtain it by
defeating its previous owner in combat
this answers the fate of the character
and Gideon has clearly been using the
powerful weapon to hunt down the
Mandalorians as we know after the
uprising at the end of Episode three
that they were pretty much made extinct
the dark saber itself is a black bladed
lightsaber that has a very distinct
design that resembles a traditional
sword due to its health and angular
pommel this extremely powerful weapon is
actually capable of powering other
lightsaber blades and it's black Kyber
crystal can also be used as a conduit
for force energy though a lot shorter
than most light sabers the blade size
and intensity changes depending on the
emotions of the person wielding it for
example the more passionate and involved
you get the bigger it becomes I've got a
sword like that it grows when you get
passionate and that nevermind it's one
of the most sought-after weapons in the
entire Star Wars universe and no doubt
gideon went to great lengths to get it
now what exactly is a moth well when it
comes to the ranking of moth this is a
high position within the empire that
actually grants the officer with a
sector of space that they have to govern
though Gideon is not a grand moff wit
which is a ranking that we've seen in
films like a new hope with Grand Moff
talking he still possesses a wealth of
control and no it's never explicitly
stated it is likely that gideon rules
over the sector of space that nabarro
exists in this is likely why he was
behind the Mandalorian extinction we
know that they were laying low on the
planet and as it's in his sector he
probably dealt with their damp
personally though we know that the
character is greatly feared in the area
it's clear that not everyone sees his
position as a bad thing and the client
even says at one point that some people
in the area would welcome back the peace
and prosperity that comes with the
Empire's ownership of the planet when
discussing his view of the character
Giancarlo Esposito who place them off
stated in a way you might call him an
underworld character but you may also
look at him as a savior as someone who
might bring back some order to the world
after its collapsed it's definitely
clear that the active use him is a hero
someone that will actually restore order
to the area from Chora Jun we do know
that after the defeat of the Empire that
the Republic did begin to get bogged
down in its own politics and the rising
of the first order can be seen as a
failing of the Republic's ability to do
its job and restore order to the planets
from the places that mondo visited it's
clear that they didn't have the level of
stability that they did under the Empire
and before I start saying make the
galaxy great again it is clear that the
Republic weren't cut out to bring order
back to the planetary systems however we
do know that when the Empire take over a
planet that they strip it of its best
resources and stamp down any notion of
freedom they also take children force
them into their ranks and and yet you
can't really win in a galaxy far far
away we do know that Gideon originally
had his sights set on baby Yoda because
he wished to clone the character and dr.
Pershing who appeared earlier in the
season was wearing the same crest at the
Kamino clonise used to so he was likely
put in place to make duplicates of the
youngling Star Wars law has changed very
heavy recently and wearers at one point
it was difficult to clone for sensitive
beings we do know now from the new
Disney trilogy that this is achievable
under the right circumstances it's
unlikely that Gideon has stopped this
quest even in the face of his crushing
defeat and the character is still now
likely so Lisa on obtaining the
youngling and also killing Dan jarring
in the process if you thought that
Gideon was bad before and you've seen
nothing yet this was him trying to
negotiate with mando and bring about
their capture as peaceful as possible
but now that he has a vendetta against
the character he will no doubt be
throwing everything that he can at the
new clan of two I can't wait for season
2 which has now been announced for fall
2020 by Jon Favreau on Twitter and who
knows what will happen when the two meet
face to face again now obviously I'd
love to hear
your thoughts on math Gideon and what
you think will be happening with the
character in the future comment below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
video then please force push that like
button and make sure you check out our
full breakdown of episode 8 which should
be linked at the end we go over all of
these threads in the final entries so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more we've also created
a full playlist of breakdowns and
characters such as baby Yoda Korra Jun
and just the show in general so
definitely give that a watch after this
if you want to come chat to me after the
video that make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey or head
over to my discourse server would you be
linked in the description below we drop
videos on there early so if you want to
see stuff before anyone else and that's
the best place to be it's free to join
and we have an awesome community so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
Joker which is one of our favorite
movies of the air and all you have to do
to be in with a chance of winning is
like the video which she subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
Mothe Gideon in the comment section
below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of January and the cell will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprise it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you